tu possède une nature très spécial
nous avons travaillé dur pour la
développer
[Applaudissements]
retire mois
[Musique]
les résultats sont dans les normes
quelque chose à signaler
je
[Applaudissements]
on est mort
le prochain contrat est très payant
la cible est le pdg de la plus grosse
corporation aux etats unis tu sera
synchronisé à kolin tête pouvons nous
permettre aucune est
prête
qu'est-ce que tu es aujourd'hui tu vas
dire quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suit opposition
ou que tu étais
tu doit en finir
qu'est ce que tu fais je peux pas
appuyer sur la détente
j'ai besoin de savoir
j'ai besoin de savoir ce qu'elle m'a
fait
il est devenu dangereux
où aller
réveille toi objecté
[Musique]
parfois
cette petite pensée c'est tout ce qu'il
faut
pour perdre le contrôle
[Musique]